an ideal world presidential candidates
would compete over who is best qualified
who was the right ideas to help America
but we live in a cartoon world and best
so instead Democrats are in a constant
woke off they're competing to see who
can embrace the dumbest most extreme
views on gender race sexual orientation
and categories you aren't thought of yet
why should another white guy be
President
well white guy who doesn't see other
identities or understand other
experiences should not be President I do
[Music]
she hurt her
[Applause]
Chadwicks more journalists in New York
seeing a very smart man a frequent guest
on our show great to see you chat with
more so I I don't know what to think
about the fact that the - whoa kiss guys
probably - not to be mean probably two
of the dumbest guys - butts wawel and
boutot are both out there woke 'no
student save them in the end should that
make me happy or sad great question i
don't know what to say do you think in
the end that the woke thing has any
appeal outside of your old neighborhood
in Brooklyn I mean really no it really
doesn't seem - unless you're talking
about donors perhaps maybe the LGBTQ
Lobby maybe college professors uh I
think maybe they're they're baking on
the youth of vote with with the woken us
but no I mean you know China's not
shaking in their boots because we want
to give free sex changes - illegals
under President Warren and and people
work it I think she mentioned you know
we're gonna help transgender illegals at
the border and whatever you know but you
know these if they're trying to skirt if
our diversity is our strength yeah then
shouldn't I mean that's a show of force
in the face of China like we're gonna
know
yeah I think I think China's a
monolithic control over their people's
actually their strength that's what the
Democrat Party is going for actually but
they might be snapping out of it because
the debates you know after that LGBT
Town Hall which was basically an episode
of Jerry Springer it was I think had a
lot of Americans cringing what's going
on here they've kind of didn't mean of
dick rat party is in there shape
shifters essentially and we've seen them
become a little more moderate when they
were in Ohio they were very very
moderate they want to talk about trade
and General Motors and we didn't see any
LGBT stuff come up in the last debate so
maybe they're they're either well it was
a little shocking and I think your
average person watching even your
average probably Republican is thinking
you know I'm not against gay people gay
people and I'm forgetting my rich what
everything you turn that thing on and we
sign up for what is this grabbing the
mic screaming talking about biology that
is like literally impossible bring
children into it yeah the same thing
most average Americans don't care they
want to write they have a live and let
live attitude whether you're a
Republican or Democrat so maybe they're
they're toning down on the locusts we
certainly they certainly didn't start
off that way but the debates have been a
little calmer but we'll see I mean now
they're focusing on more of the insane
policy like the green new deal and and
what have you
geez I don't know I can't tell either
I'm sincerely confused but I hope that
you will continue with us for the the
length and breadth of this absolutely
into insanity Chadwick more great to see
you thank you my pleasure